who do you think gets um
wifed up first do you think prudes get
wifed up like easily before like the
hose
you know it's weird um
one thing that hoes are and this is why
hoes get wifed up a lot
hoes get wifed up a lot because hoes
have perfected
they have perfected the skill of making
a man feel
good sexually right
if a man does not even a man who has the
requisite experience with women to
understand the difference between a hoe
and a prude you don't have to have any
experience you know you know you know
you know which women sleep around you
know which women generally don't
but
what what hoes
hoes have advantages over good girls the
main advantage is that they have years
and years of practice perfecting their
technique they know how to look they
know what to say they know what not to
say
croods tend to just be honest people and
they're honest because they they can be
all right well how many guys are called
a virgin i mean
if if indeed she is and so
what what um
and so by virtue of their of their
lifestyle hoes have a lot more practice
mimicking
mimicking the behavior of a quality girl
because they've done what doesn't work
right the typical 28 29 year old hoe who
sleeps around she's going to look like a
much better prospect at least in the
short term than the 21 year old who
still lives with parents and went to
catholic or christian school and happens
to still be a virgin because she doesn't
know anything but then you meet that 29
year old and
she knows how to look she knows that
actually knows how to feign
submissiveness um who gets who gets
wifed up first croods definitely get
wiped out first that doesn't mean that
hoes don't get wiped up more than prudes
because hoes there are more hoes than
prudes but in terms of pecking order
men will have fun with those like i've
had fun with many many hoes but
at the end of the day
if a man understands his worth he's not
going to commit to a hoe he'll have fun
with her maybe make her the side chick
no man of value he wants the 20 year old
who still lives with her parents who
doesn't have a high body count
so it's interesting because that is not
what i have seen
and i'm not saying this is no like facts
no data this is just like where's your
stats yeah i got none nothing
um but i see so many single girls in the
church like i know a good amount of like
25 year old virgins which i would say is
like
pretty old would you say that's pretty
old for a virgin 25
how do you know they're virgins pearl i
guess
you're right i don't know for sure so i
could say one idea is you know they're
lying and telling me that but
um the church that i like because i'm
thinking of when i lived in milwaukee
and the church in milwaukee was very
like tight-knit and very like
had i put it in each other's business so
like
like
you would like hear things through the
grapevine and so i i would know i think
i i think i would know if they would
were lying to me because like stuff just
like gets around there you know you ever
live in like a small town yeah although
like the saint yeah it's like the same
kind of like yeah
and listen there were there were there
were girls there too but they were
definitely hoes even back in 1992 so
but assuming that you're well let's just
assume for the sake of argument that
these 25 year old women are verifiable
virgins
and all that good stuff yeah yeah and
i've just seen like a lot of virgins
have like a really hard time in dating
and i think part of it is the lack of
like men in the church and maybe
unrealistic standards for those women
and like what to look for in a husband
um
but i also don't see like men of value
pursuing them because they would have to
wait to have sex and they just don't
have the time okay
yeah um so let's start with the let's
start with the first thing and i agree
with you um okay
there's a third there's actually a third
factor i'll ask you about uh in just a
second but number one yes their
standards are too high
um this doesn't mean that this doesn't
mean that i'm telling women to lower
their standards a woman can have
whatever standard she wants but what
women have to realize is that
women don't realize that there are not
many high value men
and okay so how many 25 year old virgins
are there well however many 25 year old
virgins there are i can promise you i
can promise you there are even less high
value men
90 of women pearl are competing for 10
of the men
every woman even 25 year old virgins or
women who say they're virgins or women
who don't have high body counts they
have these ridiculous expectations well
i don't want to say ridiculous
expectations they have extremely high
expectations
and at 25
if if you're a virgin at 25
and you still haven't been wifed up then
then either a you're lying about being a
virgin or b this is what i was gonna ask
you what do these girls look like
physically are they in decent shape are
they overweight because if you're 25 if
you're if you're a woman who who has who
is not overweight a woman who's in shape
and a 25 year old virgin either you're
not a virgin or there's something
physically wrong but what's the story
there um
okay i will say i would say about half
of them are like average size there's a
couple that are like pretty big but i
wasn't really thinking of them because
in my head like
there's clearly a reason like obviously
so what happens because they're
overweight right yeah
um the ones that i'm thinking of i would
say are like
five to sevens i wouldn't say any
one girl might be an eight maybe i would
say seven or eight
um but none of them are like crazy hot
to like the eight to ten category
but i would say like pretty to cute does
that make sense well pretty cute is fine
um but but to to a man of value
looking to i guess looking to uh looking
to commit long term to a woman he's got
to be sexually attracted to her that's
just all there is to it but we're not
looking for the eights nines and tens of
the world i've had enough experience
with i've had enough experiences with
eights nines and tens to understand they
belong to the streets they belong to the
game i said this i'm on episode 810 at
way back in episode 37 way back in 2000
and what 1617 i said the the downsides
to h9s and tens is that they belong to
the game they do not make good wives
they don't make good girlfriends they
don't make good mobs so we we cast those
out so the range that i tell guys to
look for just like you said is the five
to seven range in terms of looks however
if she is in if she is not overweight
and when i say oh when i say not
overweight i'm talking about a girl
who's in who who is in good shape not
decent shape because a lot of girls say
well she kind of has a decent weight or
she's an average size the average woman
in this country weighs 165 pounds that's
fat what at what height
i'm just thinking like i'm thinking of
these girls so i'm just talking about
if they're five five to five six hundred
and sixty five pounds
i would say
they're like
150 or lower
let me ask you let me ask it to you this
yeah maybe maybe this is a better answer
would a guy like me
say that those girls are overweight
um
i'd say one four like i would say one of
them you would okay but i would say the
rest no
okay so so what's the problem with them
then if they're 25 they're not
overweight but they are still virgins
it has to be it must be the expectations
and i'll tell you this
a lot of girls um a lot of girls
rightfully wait until they're trying to
wait until marriage to be in a
relationship so they start dating a guy
the guy wants to have sex with him and
guess what if i'm a high-value guy and
i'm dating a girl who is supposedly a
virgin guess what i'm going to try to
take her virginity you want to know why
because i want to know if she's i want
to know if she's really a hoe if a girl
says i'm a virgin and i sleep with on
the first date clearly not a virgin um
but but the best way for a man to [ __ ]
test a woman is to try to sleep with her
on the first date because if you sleep
with her on the first date you know she
has slept with other men on the first
date which means she is not worthy of
commitment so now we get that out of the
way so now virginal girls i guess at
your former church will say well i date
guys but then they dump me
because i'm not having sex with them if
a guy is dumping you because he's not
having sex with you that is a man who's
not looking for anything serious if a
man is looking for something serious
with a woman long-term partnership or
long-term relationship or marriage with
children and he knows you're virgin
you're telling him no i'm not going to
have sex with you until we are married
or in a relationship and he bounces
he didn't want to be in a relationship
anyway and that's not the kind of guy
you want to be with so then it goes back
then it really just goes back to the
girl so a lot of these girls are saying
well he dumped me because i'm not i'm
not having sex with him now there's this
other quandary well what if i stay with
him but then he starts sleeping with
other girls well guess what now you have
a choice to make you can either a
understand that it's just sex for him
and that he's just gonna get his rocks
off and you can wait around or b
lower your standards because men who are
able to have sex with girls are going to
be way higher value than men who
generally cannot men don't want the
average guy they want the above average
guy and one of them and the price to be
paid for it above average to a high
level elite high value guy is
understanding that he is going to stick
his sausage in other chicks
oh i disagree with that actually of
course you do i wouldn't i wouldn't
imagine i wouldn't imagine that any
woman would ever outwardly agree with
that but what women no i think i think
my dad just gave me too high of
standards he was like too good of a dad
and a father to be honest oh okay yeah
like he would he would he would never in
a million he doesn't drink he doesn't
have social media he would never in a
million years
yeah i know no one in the manner sphere
believes me but
well i mean listen i mean you know
you're i mean you seem to be you seem to
be you know a decent i mean you're not
overweight you're you know you're decent
looking i think you have a boyfriend so
but but when and and this isn't and i
would say this is not really a
generational thing but the difference
between
how can i put this
how can i put this the difference
between a man who loves a woman and a
man who doesn't is a man who really
really loves his girlfriend or wife
he's not going to let her find out that
he's smashing other chicks a lot of
people disagree with this they're like
oh my god i can't believe it if you love
her you would never step out on her no
that's that's not the case at all if you
love a woman you will never let her find
out that you're stepping out on her this
is just th this this is the male
condition now some people would say well
what if she sleeps with other guys well
then at that point the relationship is
over because when a woman sleep when
when when when a man's wife cheats on
her
men don't take back their cheating lives
at nearly the rate that women take back
their cheating husbands why because
inherently women know that sex is just
physical to men it doesn't mean that
they're okay with it doesn't mean that
it's not going to hurt but they
understand okay here's here's the thing
the first question and i've been cheated
on many times the first question that i
ask her
is is his dick bigger than mine right as
men were prideful creatures but i've
also been caught cheating and the first
question of pearl is always
do you love her and the answer is always
no i don't love her yes
and she's throwing [ __ ] and this and
that any other
but women know that sex is not about
feelings for men that doesn't mean it
doesn't hurt when they find out their
man steps out
but they understand listen as long as
you're not getting anybody pregnant i
don't see it smell it taste it let me
find out about it don't [ __ ] her at my
house don't get anybody pregnant don't
let me catch you then see no evil here
no evil really so you don't think that's
selfish
yeah it's very selfish okay
um and you don't think like some people
just have character and like choose not
to do that
not sticking your dick in other chicks
has nothing to do with character
what do you mean
like you realize like if you're if
you're hooking up with other girls even
if you don't um even if you use a condom
like you can still give your wife an sti
um and so you don't you don't think
that's like pretty selfish yeah that's
very selfish yeah that's very selfish
yeah okay um yeah listen it's very
selfish um but i would also i mean yeah
it's it's very selfish but it is what it
is
what what what we have to understand
is that i don't want to use the all's
fair in love and war but we are driven
by biology we as humans what the
difference between and i'll give you a
perfect example
a lion out in the jungle he meets with
one lioness is it wrong for him to mate
with another lioness of course not
that's his pride that his his objective
is to spread his genetic material well
what's the difference between us and
lions or other wild animals it's our
ability to reason
it's the human condition that tells us
that it's wrong that it's wrong to sleep
with other people now here's the thing
now a lot of people say okay well
donovan well what if a woman sleeps
sleeps with other people i'll put it to
you this way
one lioness
a lion okay propagates five lionesses
right that's his harem one lioness does
not take uh semen loads from five
different lions they're loyal to one
lion this is not this this is the
natural order of things it's just not
something they do and there's no reason
they're they're acting on blind instinct
in biology here's another thing if uh if
one alpha lion defeats another alpha
lion what does he do with the cubs that
are not biologically his pearl doesn't
kill them i feel like i've heard kevin
samuels say this right yeah okay
no i'm just i think i've heard this
example before
yeah
he he he kills the cubs is it okay with
the mom no but what is she to do about
it like go to another pride the point is
is that a stud horse
a stud horses used to impregnate many
mares one mare doesn't take the take the
sperm of many of many horses that's just
not the way it is but the reason why we
say cheating we call it cheating with
men we call that wrong is our ability to
reason there are feelings involved right
does that make it right or wrong
i don't think that matters the the fact
of the matter is is that we as men
we are genetically designed to reproduce
until the day we die yes the quality of
our sperm goes down when we're over 50
or 60 whatever the case may be but women
can only give birth to a finite number
of people in a finite amount of time we
as men we can procreate forever
and
i mean that's why i take morals out of
the reproduction thing because that's
just it's it's it's a human condition
that's so interesting so do you in in
your like world view or like the way you
look at it would you say that all men
cheat like regard like over um let's say
like over a certain income maybe
would you say 100 cheat
um men don't cheat they exercise options
okay yeah i know you say like they don't
cheat they have sex but you understand
what i'm asking right so men so the
right so so i'll actually put it to you
this way and i don't there's no science
to this but but
it's just like your general some stuff
is just like what you feel like well no
that's not what i feel this is this is
what happens a man who is worth let's
just say what's the man who's worth ten
figures that's a billion dollars a man
who's worth ten figures can have his
wife and a side piece living in the same
house right oh yeah oh yeah life inside
yeah because the girls will be fine with
it yeah well there you go because of his
net worth if you're worth if you're
worth a million dollars you can have a
wife and a side piece that she knows
about but you can't but she can't be
living with you right right okay she
knows about uh she knows about uh
brianna that you bang down in houston
every other month or whatever she's cool
that whatever the case may be her kids
are taken care of it's all good
if you're making a hundred thousand
dollars if you're worth a hundred
thousand dollars you can have a side
piece but your girl can't know about it
and this is all this is all dependent on
the woman because if you're worth a
hundred thousand dollars a woman is not
going to a woman is not going to stay
around if you're banging other chicks
why because there are more men who are
worth a hundred thousand dollars than
men who are worth a million dollars so
yeah the the the the the woman who was
with the man who's worth a million
dollars
okay so he's got a side piece and i know
about it but guess what my guy is a top
half percenter what am i going to do
leave him and find another millionaire
same with the millionaire the
billionaire wife well okay so diana's
living in another wing of the house what
am i going to do find another billion
dollar man so
[Music]
but half of a billion dollars is 500
million and get this okay so she leaves
and takes half what is she going to do
go date another billionaire no because
at that point i mean
well jeff bezos his wife married a
teacher yeah
you made my point for me yeah yeah
awesome so jeff bezos's wife mckenzie
bezos upgraded from the richest man on
earth to a teacher yeah do you think
it's do you think it's all about like
money when it comes to like marriage and
like happiness and a relationship
do i think it's all about money um
you don't think like character has
anything to do with it
uh character does have character has a
lot to do with it but i'm not talking
about moral character
um
i'll put it to you this way
a woman is not going to if if a man does
not make as much of a does not make as
much as his woman she can't respect him
she will want to respect him so bad but
if you are not the breadwinner you are
not going to have the respect and
subsequent love from the woman we would
love to think women women would love to
think that they could really truly love
a man
who who makes less than she does but you
guys are not nor should you be
biologically
hardwired to like a man whose net worth
i guess is lower than yours you don't
want a man to be financially dependent
upon you pearl i know this to be true
look who your father is look who your
mother is even if you come from a broken
home it is in it's in a woman's brain
and women women try this all the time
ceo at whatever 500 company she'll try
to date the guy from jiffy lube and
she'll give it the old college try
and respect it because he only makes 50
000 a year so yes money is important
when it comes to a woman's respect for
you yes there are varying degrees
depending upon depending upon whatever
situation but women do not want men to
be financially dependent upon they just